ALL AROUND.
ADRIENNE BROADDUS, APPRECIATE
THE UPDATE FOR US.
THANK YOU.
>>> NEW THIS MORNING ADIDAS HAS
OFFICIALLY SEVERED TIES WITH
KANYE WEST WHO LEGALLY CHANGED
HIS NAME IS YE.
IT IS THE LATEST BRAND TO
DISTANCE ITSELF FROM HIM AFTER A
SERIES OF OFFENSIVE ANTI-SEMITIC
COMMENTS IN RECENT DAYS.
LET'S GET A CLOSER LOOK AT WHERE
THINGS STAND THIS MORNING.
CHRISTINE ROMANS AND OLIVER
DARCY ARE HERE.
CHRISTINE, ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WAS INTERESTING IS WE HAVE
HEARD CALLS FOR DAYS, IT WAS
LAST THURSDAY THAT THE ADL CAME
OUT AND SAID, ADIDAS, WHERE ARE
YOU IN THE WAKE OF THESE
COMMENTS.
AFTER HE WORE THAT WHITE LIVES
MATTER T-SHIRT IT WAS A COUPLE
OF DAYS THEY SAID WE'RE
REVIEWING THE PARTNERSHIP.
IS THERE ANY IDEA WHY IT TOOK
ADIDAS TO TAKE SO LONG?
>> THIS IS A LONG-TERM
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN THE TWO
GOING BACK TO 2013.
KANYE WEST IS A BILLIONAIRE IN
PART DUE TO THE PARTNERSHIP WITH
ADIDAS.
THEY SAY THEY DO NOT TOLERATE
ANTI-SEMITIC AND ANY SORT OF
HATE SPEECH.
HIS RECENT COMMENTS VIOLATE THE
COMPANY'S VALUES OF DIVERSITY,
INCLUSION, MUTUAL RESPECT AND
FAIRNESS.
THE COMPANY SAYS THIS WILL HURT
THE COMPANY FINANCIALLY, THEY
KNOW THEY'RE GOING TO TAKE A
HIT, THAT HIT IS GOING TO BE
ABOUT $246 MILLION AND THE
COMPANY'S NET INCOME IN 2022
BECAUSE THEY DO HAVE SUCH A DEEP
PARTNERSHIP WITH HIM.
NO WORD IF THEY'RE GOING TO PULL
THE PRODUCTS.
I THINK THAT'S INTERESTING AS
WELL.
YOU KNOW THAT HE HAS HAD A
DIVORCE, A MESSY BREAKUP FROM
GAP OVER THEY SAY DIFFERENCES IN
MANAGEMENT OPINIONS.
UNCLEAR IF THEY'RE GOING TO BE
PULLING ANY OF THAT -- ANY OF
THAT MERCHANDISE, EITHER.
>> I FOUND SOME ONLINE THIS
MORNING.
SO IT'S STILL FOR SALE, WHETHER
THAT CHANGES AND HOW THAT ALL
SHAKES OUT WE WILL SEE.
OLIVER, AS I UNDERSTAND IT YOU
ACTUALLY JUST HEARD FROM THE
ADL.
>> YEAH, THE ADL IS PRAISING
ADIDAS FOR TAKING THE STEP BUT I
THINK IF WE LOOK BACKWARDS HERE
THIS REALLY DID TEST BUSINESSES
AND SHOW HOW MUCH HATE THEY WERE
REALLY WILLING TO TOLERATE
BEFORE CUTTING TIES WITH WEST.
IT WASN'T LIKE HE IS MAKING
THESE COMMENTS IN PRIVATE AND A
NEWS ORGANIZATION REPORTED IT
OUT.
HE WAS GOING ON THESE
ANTI-SEMITIC RANTS IN BROAD
DAYLIGHT AND IT STILL TOOK A
COUPLE WEEKS FOR THE COMPANIES
TO CUT TIES AND END THE
RELATIONSHIPS WITH KANYE WEST
AND I THINK THE SECOND QUESTION
IS WHERE DOES KANYE WEST GO NOW.
IT'S HARD TO IMAGINE OTHER
BUSINESSES ARE GOING TO WANT TO
DO -- PARTNER WITH HIM AND SO
THE QUESTION IS WHERE DOES HE
GO?
THE ONLY BUSINESS THAT'S
WELCOMING HIM WITH OPEN ARMS
RIGHT NOW IS PARLOR AND THAT'S
THIS SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORM WHICH
IS A HOT BED FOR RIGHT WING
EXTREMISM.
IT'S A TREMENDOUS FALL FOR KANYE
WEST, SOMEONE WHO IS A CULTURAL
SENSATION, PEOPLE GREW UP
LISTENING TO HIS MUSIC AND NOW
HE'S GOT TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
FOLLOWERS ON THIS REALLY RADICAL
WEBSITE WHICH HE SAYS HE WANTS
TO BUY.
>> WE SEE SOME FAMILIAR LOGOS ON
THE SCREEN, SPOTIFY AND APPLE,
CHRISTINE, SO WE KNOW AMONG
OTHER COMPANIES AND
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE CUT TIES
WITH HIM, CAA, HIS AGENTS,
TALENT MANAGEMENT AGENCY.
BUT THERE ARE CALLS ON LINE FROM
EVERY DAY PEOPLE AND OTHERS
SAYING, APPLE, SPOTIFY, OTHERS,
YOU NEED TO LOOK AT YOUR
RELATIONSHIPS.
DO WE HAVE A SENSE OF WHAT
THOSE -- I MEAN, ARE THERE
REALLY EXISTING PARTNERSHIPS OR
IS IT JUST THAT THE MUSIC IS
AVAILABLE THERE, WE THINK YOU
SHOULD PULL IT OFF?
>> HE IS AN ARTIST, A RAPPER, A
DESIGNER.
HE IS A BILLIONAIRE, RIGHT?
HE'S GOT THIS LONG TRACK RECORD
OF PRODUCTS AND MUSIC THAT IS
OUT THERE.
THE QUESTION IS I WONDER IS
THIS -- YOU KNOW, THESE CALLS TO
CANCEL HIM, THAT IS SUCH A WORD
THAT IS SO LOADED.
THERE ARE ALSO THOSE WHO ARE
SAYING SOMETHING IS HAPPENING
WITH KANYE WEST RIGHT NOW, WHAT
HE IS SAYING IS -- IS JUST --
>> IT'S FULL OF HATE.
THERE IS NO WAY AROUND IT.
>> IT'S TERRIBLE.
I DON'T EVEN WANT TO REPEAT IT
ALL, BUT THEY ARE -- I MEAN, I
DON'T KNOW HOW HE CAN GO FORWARD
AND FORGE ANY NEW PARTNERSHIPS.
HE IS SO ERRATIC HERE AND SO
HATEFUL.
WHAT IS THE UPSIDE FOR ANY BRAND
TO TIE WITH HIM OTHER THAN AS
ELDER POINTS OUT A RIGHT WING
PLATFORM FOR HATE SPEECH.
>> THE STATEMENT FROM ADIDAS
TOUCHES ON THIS.
CONSUMERS HAVE CERTAIN
EXPECTATIONS, YOUNGER CONSUMERS
ARE HOLDING BRANDS TO ACCOUNT
WHEN IT COMES TO LIVING UP TO
WHAT THEY SAY ARE THEIR
CORPORATE VALUES, RIGHT, AND
THEIR EFFORTS AT DIVERSITY,
EQUITY AND INCLUSION.
THE FACT THAT THERE WAS SILENCE
FOR SO MANY DAYS, HAS THAT
ALREADY HURT ADIDAS, OLIVER?
>> YEAH, I THINK THERE HAS BEEN
SOME BRAND DAMAGE BECAUSE THEY
JUST STOOD STILL AS HE WAS
MAKING THESE COMMENTS.
AGAIN, IT WASN'T LIKE THESE WERE
SECRET COMMENTS, THEY WERE
HAPPENING IN BROAD DAYLIGHT.
HE WAS ASKED TO APOLOGIZE FOR
THEM, INSTEAD OF DOING SO HE WAS
UNRELENTING AND HE DOUBLED DOWN,
TRIPLED DOWN ON THESE REMARKS
AND SO, YEAH, I TH